[Music]
being able to communicate effectively
with your teammates is arguably the most
important aspect of being a pro
sometimes though the microphone can pick
up something
particularly special sometimes it's
funny
sometimes it's angry and sometimes it's
just straight up weird
let's listen in now then with the top 10
voice calm moments
starting off at number 10 we have caps
locking in vain
the stakes were high it was the lec
summer 2018 playoffs and fnatic were
one-on-one in their best of five with
misfits going into game three fnatic
were discussing their next picks
now you'd think they'd go for something
safe something
tried and tested not something like
vayne mid we could see the corki again
that's a vain mid lane into a galleo
the pick seemed insane and thanks to
these voice comms
we get to hear just how shocked everyone
was
including fnatic's coach
at first the pick seemed to be a failure
fnatic fell behind and caps was
getting clapped but fnatic were patient
they knew they just had to wait out for
that late-game
vein to finally kick in
three-man knock-up heroes that just
comes in another cash
aloo asking the real questions
are there thread balls only for the
commercials or can you actually
drink them no you can actually you can
drink them
it's fine those words have become
immortalized within the cs go community
and that has become one of the most
memorable moments from katowice
2015. it didn't take long for red bull
to get in on the action
either when they referenced it on
twitter the circle
was completed in 2019 though when aloo's
new team
ents made a god tier callback
[Music]
at number eight now we've got the sounds
of sentinels winning the first ballarant
major
where he was ceiling ceiling
being our spawn he's there
tens only had a day to practice with
sentinels before balor at masters stage
one
and going into the tournament everyone
wondered if he'd had enough time to
click with his new team
but by the finals there were no doubts
anymore tens let his skills do the
talking
and the cons speak for themselves
both were there effectively with
completely 100
the calms were hype but also showed that
just because you're crushing in finals
doesn't mean you can't have a little bit
of fun it's done
this guy always bit him in i decided
spot we have fnatic cringing hard at
team liquid
unbelievable wait so why are we in the
lobby and they're not that makes no
sense
they get twenty minutes extra they're
from my life
at rift rivals 2019 league fans got to
watch
europe and north america's best teams
face off for those
sweet transatlantic bragging rights team
liquid
rep north america hard by going full
blown
captain america not only were fnatic not
impressed with the display they
questioned if team liquid even
counted as na i like how they have the
north american shield when
three out of five players on their team
is not even american don't tell anyone
why not because team liquid is the
all-american
team great hope of america nothing gets
a bit too excited now for and number six
spot
take one i got a boner let's go once you
wait yeah so
let's give this some context although
i'm not even sure that will help
cloud9 faced off against fnatic at the
esl
esea pro league season 1 finals and c9
were having a pretty bad round
and fnag won't be buying it either jw
does get a good kill
flusher almost getting caught at the
angle there but still
fnatic in control of this round but
despite the 2v3 situation
shroud bit the bullet and clutched
one spawn spawn one more
one
now you've seen the play maybe you can
see why nothing was so
excited to see his teammate pop off like
that
i got a boner let's go okay maybe we
can't explain it entirely
at the halfway point now we have
klayster laying into his team in the
call of duty league
we should have yeah we should've wanted
to get our point we should have won the
surgery under control
that was so stupid man the new york sub
liners had just lost to 100 thieves and
klayster went
in on his team for what he felt like
were some glaring mistakes
little did he know that the cdl was
actually going to broadcast these calms
right before their next game that was
really bad guys
really really really bad i don't know
what i just watched we should have yeah
we should have one [ __ ] hard point we
should have won this round we showed on
the controller
that was so stupid man we're up five
three in the search and we can't close
it out
like dude klayster showed his
disapproval with the cdl for airing the
comms during the
next game and he wasn't afraid to
elaborate on why he did it
there was no comms and then we're
sitting here watching and i saw that
they only on like released the cons with
it too
and so it was basically just kind of a
nice you know screw you before the match
i don't appreciate that i'm gonna be
having to talk with the league uh you
know if they're gonna make us sit here
and stuff like that i think it's a
little unprofessional to use the
the comms in the video from that um
especially right before we play our
match
screaming into number four now we have
the one and only
jankos
[Applause]
western fans will always remember worlds
2016 for h2ks insane run to the
semi-finals
h2k they beat ahq they beat
edg these guys are red-hot to get there
though they had to get past
edg in a tense tie breaker game it all
came down to a single dragon fight that
would give
league fans a celebration gift for years
to come
moving on to number three we have a
mysterious moan
100 thieves were looking to hold on to
their lead versus tsm
but with hiko in a 1v4 situation
he needed to pull off one of the
clutches that made him a
legend in the first place and that's
going to force the swing they want to
punish that res
this is scary because they had a lot
jesus is playing deathmatch right now
beautiful work off of the vandal
and when hiko secured the win there was
cheering
there was clapping and there was um
some mysterious moaning
we have og and lgds comms at ti-8
i don't even know what's going on i
the hour-long true sight documentary
that captured the calms behind tih's
grand
final were golden after an insane
comeback in a series in which og were
down
two to one we had jerax giving anna a
heart attack by asking if he wanted to
reload into the enemy base
for shits and giggles with millions of
dollars on the line
oh no you want to reload into the base
memes
and then there was psg lgd wondering
where sebs axes
just before he gives them a devastating
answer
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
and of course there was five friends
sharing a quiet moment of victory before
basking in
international glory
[Applause]
[Music]
and finally at number one canadian is
asking why the [ __ ]
is he so good why am i so much
better than you god damn
at the six invitational 2020 space
station found themselves down around to
tsm
and the second round wasn't looking much
better canadian was
really gonna have to pull it out of the
bag if he wanted to stay in the game
and it's canadian down below isolated
he'll walk right into geo and he wins
the fight
but he will have to find the diffuser
bullo's on only a tiny bit of hp
down goes merc bullo's one shot away
we'll canadian oh my god
no way he pulls that off and the
diffuser is his
that play was already hypers by itself
but when the voice combs were released
we got to see just how good it felt for
canadian
why am i so much you're better than you
god damn yourself get off and you
get little shits still here [ __ ]
i'm all this [ __ ] with the worst gun in
the game
you're playing twitch geo you play
twitch
all right guys which one of those was
your favorite did we miss any good ones
out
and what is the craziest thing that
you've ever heard in voice comps make
sure you let us know in the comment
section below
subscribe if you haven't done so already
thanks for watching and i'll see you all
in the next one and i'd imagine you got
to be pumped with that one
he'll start to defuse and ssg manages to
save the round
almost unwinnable i say well
he proves me wrong second round goes to
ssg
i can hear i can i'm not kidding i can
hear him
right now through through the walls